damn
welcome to zombie land just because
they're Undead doesn't mean they can't
be hilarious if Disney zombies wanted to
have done anything it showed their
viewers that zombies are just like you
and I even when it comes to making
mistakes
Addison's ed and all their fellow
friends may seem picture-perfect during
their emotional scenes and flawless
while executing some pretty intense
choreography but the truth is they're
actors messed up a lot thanks to
Disney's behind-the-scenes look and some
iconic cast tic TOCs
we put together the best bloopers from
zombies movies that will make these
already perfect films even better let's
get into it
zombies has joined the ranks of some
pretty amazing Disney originals
Camp Rock High School Musical with the
descendants but if their bloopers are
any indication they definitely brought
an added layer of humor to the table
while it takes a lot of effort to make
these hits this cast is showing us that
it doesn't mean you can't have fun even
before the director could say action
Milo Manheim and Trevor Tordjman also
known as Dutton Bucky were already
creating some memorable bloopers looks
like Milo got his wish it is the Disney
Channel after all in life sometimes
things just don't go your way the same
applies when you're on the set of a
movie just ask Meg Donnelly and Kingston
Foster or as you probably know them
Addison and Zooey bloopers are most of
the time due to human error but
sometimes they just can't be prevented
while meg was filming her breathtaking
number stand her golden locks wanted a
moment to shine to all she wanted to do
was fight for equality this take might
not have been as powerful and perfect as
what we originally saw on screen but you
have to admit it's pretty hilarious
Zedd sure loved it imagine being nine
years old and getting in front of a
crowd of people and rows of cameras you
might even get anxious thinking about it
now but little zoey took it like a champ
even when her pom-poms didn't exactly
cooperate luckily for her she had a
super supportive cast behind her
cheering her on even with just one
pom-pom she just shrugged it off and
gave the amazing performance we saw in
the film's final take it just goes to
show how close the cast really is
instantly not chin if he thought Zed was
goofy just wait until you see how
eccentric Milo was behind the scene just
take a look of his dramatic rendition of
what looks like him squeezing someone's
arm really hard maybe he was rehearsing
for an upcoming scene or maybe the
choreography he had to learn was getting
him a little riled up basically this
means Milo is said in real life
confirmed maybe without all the zombie
stuff though when most people make
mistakes or mess something up they get
embarrassed we don't exactly know if
these bloopers were embarrassing for the
cast but we do know that they came from
some pretty hilarious facial expressions
seriously they're borderline meme worthy
Trevor definitely looks like he ate
something sour in his shot or maybe
that's his reaction to a cheer pyramid
gone wrong peace signs and scrunching
your face what's that all about miss
Leakes usually we can't forget about
bonta's hardcore DJ face deadmau5 poo
and then there's that being very very
very confused about his mistake
great no though a new musical means
constantly dancing and singing day in
and day out apparently even when the
cameras are rolling coach had an entire
jam session to himself that was caught
on camera unfortunately his solo never
made the cut but Disney knew who was
definitely something viewers would want
to see I shouldn't I really go to that
Coach isn't the only minor character
looking for their moments to shine
Devon and del also got the cameras
attention when they broke out an
imaginary dance floor for their number
maybe it was even a plan duet
either way they absolutely slayed it
right
remember the presidential debate in
zombies 2 between rivals Zedd and Becky
that was definitely an intense time but
behind the scenes it was nothing but fun
and games for the actors in fact they
really wanted to add their own twist to
the dance number just look at their very
unique dance moves maybe it was for the
best this clip didn't make the final cut
but we're sure glad they still released
it like we talked about before the
presidential debate was definitely a
stressful point in the movie although
Addison and Ed spent the entire first
film working to build a community of
unity between humans and the zombies
they still face some challenges in the
second film the debate was so stressful
that in this version things got violent
just kidding this shows how close the
actors Milo and Trevor are off-screen
they definitely aren't like their
characters when it comes to their
friendship it isn't only while reciting
lines that we see actors having major
slip-ups breaking character during a
dance number was definitely a common
occurrence on the set of zombies it
looks like no matter how often they
rehearsed they definitely needed to film
those huge numbers multiple times so we
know how talented these stars are they
got back out there like professionals
and nailed all of their favorite musical
scenes it's insane but speaking about
reciting lines there were definitely
some keepers when it came to the actors
for getting the script
Addison spends both movies fighting for
equality and for everyone's right to be
who they are no matter what and
Addison's actress meg is apparently very
forgetful when it comes to memorizing
lines from cheer practice to prom night
to seeing Dombey land for the first time
Meg's sprinkled her hilarious bloopers
all over their takes but don't worry Meg
we love you more for it I don't even
Milo is also no stranger to messing up
his lines although from what Disney
showed us it wasn't as often as Meg
there was however one time when he
forgot the entire scene and had to walk
off of the set completely zombie with
how flawless the movie performed their
hit BAM you wouldn't think Milo had just
made a pretty hilarious fumble but he
did and even Meg was confused not to
mention the time he completely walked
onto the set when he wasn't supposed to
perfect but forgetting their lines was a
common occurrence even outside of the
main characters
Eliza also known as Kylie Russell had a
few of her own slip-ups that in good old
Eliza fashion ended with the sari and
some contagious laughing she probably
had everyone on set laughing along with
her while her empowering and encouraging
speeches were everything and helped a
lot of her friends through tough times
these bloopers were equally as
entertaining all right we can't forget
about Bucky cheer practices are a huge
deal in the movies and we're always
taken super seriously or that's what we
originally thought look at the time
Bucky completely messed up this cheer
practice scene meg also had a pretty big
blooper during the scene it must have
been a pretty long day on set it worked
out in the end because who doesn't enjoy
a good old blooper reel some people
might even say they're better than
watching the actual movie
[Music]
remember when we watched Devin and Dell
dance it out in an earlier blooper that
wasn't the only blooper they were part
of you know that feeling when you go in
for an excited high-five and you
completely miss awkward right well this
exact thing happens as Evan and Dell
except on camera they totally saved it
though they quickly know the double
high-five right after we would expect
nothing less from Zed and Zoe's father
has anyone come up with their bromance
ship name yet when this iconic cast
wasn't embodying their characters
stepping into their dancing shoes or
warming up their vocal cords they were
making contents for another platform Tik
Tok ever heard the say in a cast that
tick-tocks
together stays together from capturing
behind the scenes bloopers to performing
class renegade as a whole cast these
actors weren't afraid to take fans with
them for the ride and we were pretty
sure those fans are super happy they
recorded everything from intense
laughing sessions to freestyle rapping I
mean it's a musical they even dance to
Old Town Road
who hasn't tik-tok was probably the best
b-roll they could have shared with
viewers forgetful Zedd has a nice ring
to it
and after you watch this next looper
you'll get why it'd be the perfect
nickname for Milo on set we talked about
actors for giving their lines and props
just not cooperating but what about the
actors for getting their proper entirely
in the scenes ed is preparing for his
presidential speech but when Eliza asks
him to pull it out
he breaks character and realizes it
wasn't in his jacket pocket where it was
supposed to be pilot took it like a
champ and laughed along with Milo good
thing he found it
Addison said maybe the OTP of our dreams
but just because they got together
doesn't mean zombies 2 was all smooth
sailing the angst was strong in this
sequel that just didn't get her but who
knew that behind the scenes
Addison punching Zedd would actually be
hilarious at least Addison found it
funny said not so much I think it's safe
to say these two not only have the best
scenes but the best bloopers together
it's no wonder they've sparked a bunch
of dating rumors in real life
[Music]
if you're like us you are definitely
jealous you couldn't be having fun in
that bright pink obstacle course with
the rest of the cast during the opening
scene of zombies - well apparently we
were right to feel that way because the
cast thought it was so much fun and yes
even rolling around in the mud part
while this isn't exactly a blooper
we're pretty sure navigating this
obstacle course came with a lot of
challenges just take a look at this
behind-the-scenes footage of the cast
although it looked messy and tiring Meg
described as a great action-packed way
to start shooting but it's actually our
job if these bloopers taught us anything
it's how close this cast really is
they say you choose your family and
while we don't know these actors
personally it sure looks like filming
these two movies has made them extremely
close the best thing to come out of
bloopers is always the laughter and
we're pretty sure a lot of the memories
the cast will take with them happens
behind the scenes and not during the
picture-perfect moments we saw play out
on screen thanks to Disney we got a peek
into all these good memories just take a
look at the laughs and hugs they enjoyed
on set the idea of filming a huge Disney
movie already seems like so much fun and
after watching these flippers I think
it's safe to say that the behind the
scenes action and slip-ups are probably
the best part of the experience it's
crazy they give us a peek and what the
actors behind our favorite characters
are really like and give us a glimpse
into what it's like filming a huge
budget film not to mention these
bloopers let us see that the cast of
zombies is actually a really big family
as they say an old zombie tongue bizarre
nutty gar Zayn gar stick what was your
favorite blooper did watching the cast
mistakes change the way you feel about
the movies what do you think some of
your bloopers would be if you were an
actor let us know in the comments
section below don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and give these zombies
bloopers a thumbs up for more behind the
scenes videos just like this one see you
in Zombieland